he's losing that game and this  is hikaru's reaction to that  um when he's realizing he's losing  to fellow american sam shanklin what'd  you take from this david  um i i wish yeah i mean  i i feel bad for him because yeah we all  hate  we've all been there right when we've um  we've made a bad move and  kind of let the wind slip and um yeah  he'll come back he's a champ  like he's a winner he'll come back but  yeah it is it is incredibly painful  everything is intensified when you're  playing online chats and especially such  a situation like this when he was so  close to winning  and so close to comfortably qualifying  um yeah hikaru nakamura and he knows  obviously  being an online tournament he's a huge  favorite um we haven't looked at this  game so we're not quite sure what's  happening in the game  when he's